la saison des galettes c'est pour
bientôt et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour les gourmands que nous sommes tous
dès que Noël sera passé elle devrait
commencer à apparaître dans les vitrines
des artisans boulangers pâtissiers avec
un peu d'avance on en a déjà croisé
aujourd'hui sur le campus des métiers de
jouer les tours à l'occasion du Concours
national de la meilleure galette aux
amandes l'année dernière le prix avait
été remporté par un boulanger de Château
Renault cette année il a rejoint les
membres du jury romain Delville a suivi
pour nous ce concours d'exception Hervé
baudé est passé de l'autre côté de la
barrière l'an dernier le pâtissier de
Château Renault remporter le premier
concours national de la meilleure
galette aux amendes cette année il fait
partie du jury faut bien qu'il a un
petit feuillet entre chaque couche de
feuilletage pour amener un petit
croustillant c'est ça qui fait le côté
fondant le petit côté croustillant en
même temps dans dans le feuilletage et
c'est ça qui qui amène le côté savoureux
qu'on peut apprécier sur une galette
équilibre entre le feuille et la
frangipane présentation motif chaque
juré a sa sensibilité selon son histoire
et sa culture le goût de la mand mer est
assez souvent retrouvé dans les dans les
galettes en Moselle en tout cas dans
l'Est on est près de l'Alsace on a des T
de de tradition qui reste lié à notre
histoire allemande finalement une chose
est sûre c'est que gagner le concours
national ça dope les ventes de la
galette on était à 2000 galettes nous
somt passés à 8000 galettes sur
l'équivalent un mois ça a changé
beaucoup beaucoup de production
l'organisation un effectif de personnel
au taquet pour pour faire pour maintenir
cette production de galett donc
maintenant on va essayer de reproduire
autant de galettes pour l'année
prochaine on va essayer pendant de
années le ou la vainqueur du concours ne
peut pas se présenter Hervé baudé compte
bien retourner dans la compétition dès
qu'il le
pourra y